[Musique]
de Gaulle là en pleinement marqué de son
empreinte l'histoire française du XXe
siècle mais comment s'est forgé celui
qui est devenu l'homme du 18 juin celui
qui a dit non à la défaite de 1940 une
partie des réponses figurées vous venez
de le voir dans ce documentaire réalisé
par Xavier Marie Bonnot et nous allons
maintenant débattre plus au-delà avec
nos invités présents aujourd'hui sur ce
plateau de débat doc avec vous pour
commencer Jean-Luc Barré bienvenue vous
êtes historien écrivain et directeur des
éditions bouquins votre dernier ouvrage
s'intitule le corps d'origine publié
chez grassel l'histoire d'un ancien
Premier ministre candidat à la
présidentielle est mouillée dans une
histoire de crime et demeure et puis en
lien direct cette fois avec notre
émission nous citrons devenir de Gaulle
ouvrage publié aux éditions Perrin et
puis à venir c'est à signaler ça sera
chez Grasset ce sera en trois volumes et
ça sera pour l'automne prochain une
biographie consacrée à de Gaulle
intitulé De Gaulle une dont le premier
volume s'intitulera l'homme de personne
1890 la date de naissance de De Gaulle
jusqu'à 1944 premier volume à découvrir
donc en octobre prochain et ça sera chez
Grasset Christine Clerc est également
avec nous bienvenue et vous êtes grand
porteur et chroniqueuse notamment au
Télégramme de Brest et aussi le modèle
le point votre dernier livre s'appelle
lui Dominica la diabolique en référence
à un célèbre fait divers de l'année
1959 et pour cette émission nous
conseillons la lecture de votre ouvrage
Les de Gaulle une famille française
disponible aux éditions NiL voici la
couverture de ce livre à se procurer
donc aux éditions ni Laurent Joffrin est
également avec nous bienvenue vous êtes
journaliste éditorialiste et passionné
d'histoire tout le monde ne le sait pas
par on connaît le directeur de
publication le journaliste mais vous
êtes un vrai passionné d'histoire
Laurent Joffrin vous êtes aujourd'hui le
directeur de publication de le journal
pour info c'est un nouveau quotidien
numérique à découvrir en ligne doublé
d'une newsletter d'ailleurs vous êtes
par ailleurs le président fondateur du
mouvement les engagés pour le
rassemblement je cite de la gauche
sociale écologique et républicaine et
votre dernier livre s'intitule Léning du
Code Noir publié aux éditions Buchet
Castel
Jean-Luc Barret on découvre ce qui a été
le évidemment le contexte où
s'effectuait la jeunesse de Charles de
Gaulle et on nous décrit une famille
profondément catholique monarchiste et
aussi légaliste qu'est-ce qui explique
dans les origines familiales de De
Gaulle le Charles de Gaulle qu'on a
connu par la suite d'abord il y a
d'abord il y a ce empreinte monarchiste
qu'il va dépasser lui-même mais enfin
elle est là je crois que c'est il
apprend aussi un certain sens de la
continuité historique il est plus
parisien si vous voulez le plus proche
de Maurice Barrès qui pensait que il
fallait dans la vision de la France je
fais la intégrer toute l'histoire de
France contre contrairement à Moras qui
ne voulait retenir que la monarchie donc
à l'idée de la continuité nationale vous
citez barrez
qui sont des qui sont des pères
spirituels un petit peu de gopapa
morasme
spirituel de De Gaulle il est le père de
Charles de Gaulle était un Mauricien
authentique la mère était très très elle
était bigote elle était très imprégnée
mais c'est une femme très intelligente
en même temps qui a beaucoup marqué
Charles peut-être plus que son père
encore faire le moral patron du de
l'Action française du Journal de
l'Action française
nationaliste mais aussi antisémite
notoire oui je connais déjà de Gaulle ce
qui était pas évidemment pas Charles de
Gaulle mais il baigne dans ce milieu là
et au fond il va s'affranchir de ce
milieu en même temps il il restera
imprégné des valeurs
politiques morales la grandeur de la
France enfin toutes ces notions là
qu'évidemment sont capitales donc il est
formé dans cette famille par cette
famille et la haine du BOSCH parce que
son frère son père a fait la guerre 70
et il nous est dit dans ce documentaire
que son peigne son lui enseigne la haine
de l'allemand ça me paraît pas juste non
il y a l'idée de la revanche mais c'est
pas la haine d'ailleurs de Gaulle est
très imprégnée de culture allemande
beaucoup plus de culture que de culture
anglaise d'ailleurs quand il va arriver
à Londres il connaît bien moins la
culture Anglaise qui ne connaît la
culture allemande donc il y a pas de
haine de l'Allemagne il y a l'idée de la
revanche donc c'est une conception qui
était passée à de Gaulle il y a pas la
haine de notre peuple a priori mais il y
a le désir d'en découdre avec un pays
qui lui-même d'ailleurs veut en découdre
avec la France parce que la guerre de 14
c'est évolue des deux côtés donc il se
prépare à ça au fond il se prépare à
devenir un soldat et c'est pas
exactement d'ailleurs la carrière qu'il
va avoir contrairement à ce que l'on
pense parce qu'au fond il se dessine à
devenir une sorte de d'humourier de
Turenne de Hoche c'est le rêve de son
adolescence quand il a 15 ans il imagine
déjà le général de Gaulle pour lui
l'accomplissement de sa vie c'est d'être
un grand chef militaire et c'est
d'ailleurs aussi une manière de de
réparer un petit peu ce qui a été la
carrière à portée de son père qui n'a
pas pu être un soldator à cause de la
guerre de 70
professeur etc voilà on y reviendra sans
doute mais à un moment de bascule très
important dans la ville de Gaulle pour
moi c'est la période de la captivité si
on ne si on ne part pas de cette période
de la captivité de la grande guerre ou
en fait il est empêché de faire la
guerre même si les blessés même s'il va
se battre etc mais l'essentiel de la
guerre il l'a pas emprison on comprend
pas ce qu'elle va être la mutation
fondamentale de sa vie sur ce contexte
familial on découvre aussi un enfant
frondeur qui aura horreur de perdre qui
prend souvent le dessus sur ses cousins
c'est ses autres frères des questions de
jeu familiaux
de la loi sur la laïcité qui est qui
empêche les religieux d'enseigner en
France parce qu'à l'époque c'était
beaucoup plus sévère qu'aujourd'hui et
les Jésuites n'ont plus le droit
d'enseigner en France et donc il part
avec un de ses frères pensionnaires en
Belgique
dans un dans un institution extrêmement
rigoureuse parce que l'eau qui coule des
robinets en hiver gel il y a pas de
chauffage c'est vraiment une éducation à
la rue à la dure et en même temps il est
passionné parce qu'il est matin midi et
soir c'est c'est une jeunesse
entièrement vouée à apprendre à lire à
écrire déjà réfléchir bon et ensuite
quand il sera en prisonnier des
Allemands avec trois tentatives
d'évasion je crois mais entre temps il
va lire aussi il va donner des cours à
ses camarades donc la formation
intellectuelle et prodigieuse quand on
pense à l'époque d'aujourd'hui voilà
pour un pour un adolescent
jeune homme c'est ahurissant le la place
occupée par le par le savoir par
l'instruction
on a cité barré ce Mora Charles Péguy
est situé dans ce film aussi en
arrière-plan il y a un fort nationaliste
tout de même bien sûr faut pas oublier
le contexte
un grand mère qui avait connu la guerre
de 18 70
on va d'une guerre à l'autre et à chaque
fois la France est battue et humilié
c'est quand même parce que 14 on a cru
qu'on avait gagné mais enfin si on
n'aurait pas gagné sans les Américains
comme ça va être le cas en 40 en 1870
c'est une grand-mère qui leur raconte la
chute de Napoléon III et tout c'est ce
sont que des histoires de chutes donc
c'est vrai que ça marque profondément un
jeune homme qui est qui lui rêve de
redresser la France et se voit déjà en
général on va voir un extrait du
documentaire c'est Serge Bernstein qui
évoque l'anti parlementarisme
de Charles de Gaulle et on en parle tout
de suite après avec vous Laurent Joffrin
la République n'aime guère l’armée et
l'armée le lui rend bien les
déclarations qu'on connaît de lui sont
toujours l'idée que la République rend
la France impuissante que du coup elle
risque d'être accablé par l'ennemi qui
lui a un régime fort etc que
au Parlement perd son temps bavardage au
lieu d'agir donc il y a une culture
nettement anti-parlementaire alors je
sais pas si c'est dû au contexte
familial qu'on a évoqué ensemble juste
avant mais les décrit par Serge Marsan
par comme un anti parlementariste très
clairement suite à cette éducation ses
lectures qu'on a évoqué précédemment
une limite à ça c'est que quand il est
revenu en 44 il a établi un régime
républicain il a hésité au début entre
40 et 41 la France Libre hésite un peu
on n'ose pas mettre liberté égalité
fraternité sur les documents parce que
la République c'est la défaite mais bon
quand même à la fin des fins
de Gaulle rétabli et la Cinquième
République c'est une république
présidentielle mais comment on sait elle
est assez souple et quand il y a une
cohabitation mais elle devient une
république parlementaire et quand il y a
pas de majorité question de mettre en
place la Quatrième République et
quittera
le régime des parties c'est pas un
militaire factieux quoi c'est pas un
type qui veut prendre le qui veut
devenir un dictateur surtout pas 67 ans
selon la conférence de presse de 58 il
accepte finalement l'héritage
républicain avec beaucoup de distance
avec beaucoup de méfiance mais il
accepte quand même et d'ailleurs je
trouve que ce qui est intéressant dans
le dans la jeunesse dans la formation
c'est il y a quand même un grand
paradoxe c'est un militaire une censé
obéir il désobéit mais de manière la
plus spectaculaire qui soit c'est un
c'est un stratège un spécialiste de la
technique militaire ils passent son
temps à lire des romans une grande
partie de ses lectures ce sont des
romans quand il écrit ses mémoires de
guerre il relie tout Châteaubriand
et manifestement alors je sais pas vous
savez mieux que moi il veut devenir il
aurait voulu devenir un grand écrivain
qu'il est en partie d'ailleurs puisque
quand même c'est c'est il a quand même
un style formidable qui est un peu
classique tout ce qu'on veut moi c'est
pas novateur matière de style mais quand
même c'est bien fait et donc c'est
l'être magnifique donc c'est un homme
tout d'une pièce et qui lit des romans
où il n'y a que des nuances que vous des
notations psychologiques des choses
subtiles etc et ce qu'il était lui-même
c'est-à-dire qu'il y avait là on est sur
un des paradoxes du personnage comme ça
parce que c'était un nationaliste
quelqu'un qui est attaché à la terre aux
morts on racine aux héritages et il a
d'emblé une vision mondiale
les gens d'extrême droite aujourd'hui
disent de Gaulle c'est notre homme
il a le temps à savoir mais ils disent
ça mais c'est pas du tout ça eux ils ont
une vision très étriquée de la France il
y a un moment il y a un tournant
important à propos du nationalisme de
Gaulle de qu'on a jamais assez bien
souligné me semble-t-il c'est le
tournant de la Dominique parce que il
est sans doute assez nationaliste en
tout cas il est assez
anti-parlementariste c'est évident ne
serait-ce que d'ailleurs parce que le
système est-ce qu'il est
et d'ailleurs qui va le prouver au
moment de Munich entre autres et on
parle de la deuxième république et là il
s'aperçoit que les nationalistes je
parle pas de la gauche qui se comporte
pas beaucoup mieux puisque Bloom parle
d'un lâche soulagement etc au monde
munique même unique je rappelle que
c'est le moment où on va lâcher
finalement entre les mains des Hitler la
Tchécoslovaquie et finalement le reste
de l'Europe centrale et à ce moment-là
de Gaulle voit que les nationalistes les
fameux nationalistes
d'extrême droite Morace et autres
approuve d'une manière d'une autre
Munich et il est un des rares finalement
à désapprober minute alors qu'il n'est
pratiquement rien et que sa voix ne peut
pas être entendue ils sont quelques-uns
un peu à gauche un peu à droite à
réprouver Munich je pense qu'il y a un
tournant dans le dans l'idée
nationaliste de De Gaulle qu'il va
vérifier au monde Vichy puisque font une
grande partie des nationalistes se
trouve aussi à Vichy certains sont avec
lui mais la majorité sont donc il y a un
moment où il dépasse ce qui est très
important sur me comprendre de Gaulle
c'est les mutations successives si on
comprend bien ça on va l'évolution il y
a des lignes de force il y a une ligne
de pensée il y a des visions très
claires on parlera peut-être des
questions coloniales et autres tout
ailleurs mais on voit bien que très tôt
il a une vision des choses et c'est pas
du pragmatisme c'est c'est le fait que
l'histoire évolue et que il se rend
compte il dépasse au fond ses propres
origines et ses propres visions de
départ en tout cas c'est propre
conception familiales etc et quand quand
quelques jours avant le 18 juin il fait
un pacte avec Staline avec avec chels
pardon avec Churchill pour créer une
seule nation franco-anglaise c'est quand
même formidable
pour essayer d'aller convaincre nous
enfin bon il y croit parce que
finalement comme Churchill il pense que
c'est la dernière chance quoi et c'est
pourtant qui avait quand même un océan à
franchir plus que plus que la Manche et
en plus oui mais il a des trucs d'audace
où il est pas sous le monde et à la
Libération quand il va son premier
voyage en Allemagne quand je veux dire
en Alsace quand il quand il parle de
réconciliation avec les Allemands et les
il est très mal vu il est trop rapide il
a mais toujours il a il a des années
d'avance et il prépare le terrain
discours après discours ont laissé
faisant passer des éléments de langage
mais on se dit mais non mais il est fou
ce type là ça va pas non mais là le
pacte avec l'Allemagne
l'union avec l'Allemagne non c'est même
pas si qui voit quand même l'Europe à
venir c'est pour ça que aujourd'hui on
ne sait jamais ce que ce qu'il dirait ce
qu'il ferait parce qu'il avait toujours
20 ans d'avance Jean-Luc Barré évoquait
une autre rupture c'est la captivité
durant la Première Guerre mondiale
il est blessé une première fois sur le
front belge au tout début des hostilités
en étant dans le durant l'été 1914 et
puis surtout il y aura à Verdun avec un
certain
général Pétain à l'époque
blessé il passe pour mort ensuite
captivité durant deux années ça aura été
réellement un tournant de l'homme de
Gaulle et du militaire de Gaulle il en a
fait une captivité on a fait une déprime
de pas avoir pu combattre alors que ses
frères combattaient là c'était c'était
très dur pour lui d'avoir été prisonnier
ne pas avoir été au front et d'avoir
raté ces évasions
ça me fait partie des moments
de déprime parce que pour moi c'est sa
sensibilité est grande même si elle est
j'allais dire caché masqué par par
l'uniforme par l'obligation d'assumer
mais en même temps il passe il passe par
des moments de déprime et puis jouer ou
pas jouer d'ailleurs parce que
quelquefois il ajoute la déprime quand
il dit qu'il va s'en aller
il faut tout le monde le retienne on le
retient pas toujours voilà et alors là
il a une vraie déprime pour le coup
alors il publiera plusieurs essais
durant l'entre-deux-guerres les discorde
chez l'ennemi le fil de l'épée vers
l'armée de métiers en 1934 la France et
son armée en 1938 tous ces livres sont
évoqués dans le film que nous avons vu
que vous époque cette que vous évoque
cette carrière militaire de
l'entre-deux-guerres entre la Première
Guerre mondiale cette période de la
captivité et puis le fameux 18 juin
34 ans plus 47 ans quand il publie ses
ouvrages parce qu'on a tendance à le
croire toujours vieux
et là ça fait partie des paradoxes il a
pas pu faire la guerre parce qu'il était
prisonnier est-ce qu'il a beaucoup
meurtri et moralement et ensuite il
fallait quand même être un grand soldat
et j'ai l'impression c'est l'hypothèse
qui l'a fait en étant meilleur
théoricien militaire que tous ces
collègues
il a donné les cours à l'autre à l'école
de guerre toute une série de cours qui
était très charpentée etc et donc il
expliquait assez à ses collègues comment
il fallait faire la guerre alors que lui
il n'avait pas vraiment fait un peu
quand même mais assez peu finalement il
a pas commandé une grande unité c'est ça
mais il expliquait comment il fallait
faire et et
sa culture qui était énorme historique
politique
est technique militaire et son ouverture
d'esprit parce qu'il était ouvert sur la
technologie
aujourd'hui on dirait la technologie à
l'époque on disait la technique
aujourd'hui ça fait un peu en
technologie c'est plus long flan mais
c'est la même chose
on peut généralement
à la mobilité des unités blindées
comment ça marchait comme on pouvait les
organiser comment elle pouvait
communiquer entre elles et il était
ouvert tout ce qui était innovation
comme on dirait aujourd'hui c'est là
aussi voulant c'est ce qui dit dans le
film mais vous m'en direz un mois après
j'imagine pénétrer la sphère politique
de l'époque qu'il remporte il rencontre
il y a des lettres à Raynaud qui sont
d'une sécurité incroyable quoi vous êtes
un génie etc il a quand même une idée
fixe même s'il a pas autant fait la
guerre qu'il aurait voulu il a quand
même une idée fixes ce sont les chars et
pense qu'il faut qu'on s'équipe de
blinder et les premiers à le lire
vraiment ça a été les Allemands qui se
sont inspirés de lui parce que le fameux
buderian qui réussir à lui le blues
malgré tous les articles et livres
publiés
il faut peut-être contextualiser est-ce
qu'il prêche dans le désert est-ce que
c'est un casium seul à prêcher c'est
théories militaire de la guerre mobile
de la il a affaire une armée totalement
ce sclérosée c'est à dire cette armée
elle pense d'abord qu'elle a gagné la
Grande Guerre ce qui est pas totalement
juste elle n'a pas perdu mais il a pas
non plus gagné et elle est en Lisée dans
une sorte de conformisme Pétain est déjà
un homme très âgé en 1918 quelque part
et tous les tas major est très
conservateurs etc et lui a une idée qui
est celle d'opposer pour résumer les
choses à la théorie de Pétain qui est
celle de la guerre du jure autrement dit
on prend son temps pour selon des
formules classiques pour gagner une
guerre à la guerre de mouvement qui
passe effectivement par l'utilisation
d'une d'une technique ou d'une
technologie nouvelle donc il est
radicalement opposé à tout ce que
l'état-major pense le seul qui pensait
avoir la même chose c'est Foch mais il y
avait déjà longtemps et donc il s'oppose
à tout cela dans des cris avec beaucoup
de courage et publie des livres sans
autorisation de l'armée enfin il est
déjà un espèce de rebelle en puissance
est-ce qu'il se dit il faut que je
pénètre cette fameuse faire politique
de mon cornet
des chars
la tête d'une division de char en 48
cette quête du pouvoir du côté de la
sphère politique c'est quelque chose qui
est très perceptible dans les années 30
par exemple c'est quelque chose chez De
Gaulle qui mature et
le pouvoir c'est l'histoire c'est
l'histoire de France bien sûr c'est le
passionnant aussi on passe pas par le
pouvoir on obtient rien et comme il voit
qu'il faut absolument réformer l'armée
l'armement que l'Allemagne s'arme que la
France est toujours à la remorque il n'y
a pas d'autre solution que de passer par
le pouvoir politique
donc j'ai une hypothèse mais là aussi je
parle sous votre contrôle parce que je
connais bien le l'itinéraire de
Bonaparte jusqu'à jusqu'à la fin de
l'Empire
j'ai l'impression que la doctrine
gaulliste est une partie de l'itinéraire
en tout cas ça correspond je sais pas si
c'est inspiré de ça mais les idées de
réconciliation nationale d'être
au-dessus des parties de venir
obtenir cette réconciliation grâce à une
gloire acquise sur la scène
internationale comme Bonaparte l'avait
fait de Gaulle c'est l'homme de 40
Bonaparte c'était l'homme de Rivoli un
peu la même chose et qui vient en disant
je ne suis aucun parti
de la part disait ni talon rouge ni
bonnet rouge et de Gaulle disait je suis
au-dessus des parties
la République est divisée il faut le
retrouver son unité par la grandeur tout
ça c'est l'air athéorique de Bonaparte
et de Napoléon III sous une forme plus
ridicule mais mais on a l'impression que
c'est de même l'idée de s'adresser au
peuple en classe populaire et pas direct
pas seulement aux élites il faut d'abord
les élites avec soi ou les subjuguer par
la gloire mais de parler et d'avoir une
force de communication et de propagande
auprès des classes populaires et
y compris dans le spectacle et dans le
verbe parce que les deux et Bonaparte et
de Gaulle ont une culture littéraire
approfondie il savait écrire ils savent
ils ont le sens de la formule choc qui
frappe le pignon et ils ont le sens du
comment dire du décorum du spectacle
alors de Gaulle c'était naturel il est
plus grand que tout le monde il a pas
besoin de se un mec 93 on la prend les
plus petits là il était obligé de se
déguiser pour qu'on le reconnaisse tout
de suite du coup on a pas besoin mais il
y a cette idée les deux bras écartés
comme ça il y a toute une gestuelle qui
revient en permanence et de Napoléon
c'était la main comme ça de Gaulle c'est
les bras comme ça mais mais il y a cette
idée qu'un homme politique qu'un homme
d'État doit se reconnaître tout de suite
du discours populaire faut pas oublier
que un dans la résistance il a eu quand
même pas mal de gens de différents
milieux et de gauche et de la Libération
le Parti communiste est extrêmement
puissant donc il doit jouer avec le
Parti communiste qui fait plus de 30%.
et dont ils se demandent s'il cherche
pas à prendre le pouvoir c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il fallait voir Staline
bon mais
à la fois il faut qu'il y l'épouse une
partie d'un qui sera beaucoup plus
populaire beaucoup plus à gauche si on
peut dire que ce à quoi on pouvait
s'attendre de la part d'un général et
en même temps il faut oui il faut qu'il
appelle et qu'il empêche les autres de
prendre le pouvoir par un coup de force
parce que constamment on le voit la
libération pendant toutes les semaines
où il parcourt la France à chaque fois
il trouve même des communistes armées il
exige qui posent leur revolver sur la
table etc c'est
il y a vraiment une lutte de force pour
le pouvoir
donc pour vaincre il faut à la fois
montrer son autorité et en même temps
avoir un discours qui était celui
de la résistance qui est un discours
socialement très à gauche
le gouvernement de 43 il y a un peu tout
le monde et il dit au fond c'est moi le
seul révolutionnaire parce qu'il est
d'abord une vision il y a un moment il y
a un tournant très important chez De
Gaulle dans ses toujours à partir de 41
où il prend conscience quand même de des
évolutions des révolutions qu'il va
falloir opérer la libération
système sur le sur le plan économique
sur le plan social c'est là où d'une
certaine manière il se rapproche de la
gauche en même temps sur les communistes
récemment j'ai trouvé une anecdote de
l'État il est à Rennes et le primate
Bretagne
lui dit mais enfin vous savez ce qu'on
dit dans mon milieu alors le
géraldinemont souvent de la Libération
il dit mais on dit que vous êtes très
proche des communistes et il répond mais
enfin écoutez les catholiques qui dit ça
n'avaient qu'à être là donc quelque part
ça veut dire beaucoup de choses ça veut
dire qu'il fait avec ce qui existe et
les communistes sont peut-être des
communistes mais en 41 après le patch
soviétique bien sûr mais il se battent
quoi donc il fait avec eux enfin il va
prendre très vite le contrôle de tout ça
quand même alors il y a quelque chose
qui n'est pas évoqué dans ce
documentaire mais Charles de Gaulle
c'est un grand nostalgique de l'Empire
français ça fait partie de sa culture
aussi je crois de la culture non je
crois pas du tout ah non je crois que
c'est non sens parce que pardon on peut
dire ça qu'il avait ça avec
deux grandes nostalgiques de leurs
empires respectifs l'Empire britannique
et l'Empire français je crois que quand
de Gaulle en 1912 a le choix à sortir de
Saint-Cyr entre l'infanterie on reste en
Artois et dans le Nord dans l'Est de la
France ou partir dans l'empire ce que
vont faire la plupart des militaires il
choisit la première option parce qu'il
fait partie de ceux avec Clémenceau est
mort ce qui ne croient pas l'Empire
français qui pensent que tôt ou tard
cette empire va se disloquer en 1931 il
fait un discours je vais vite à au Liban
à Beyrouth où il appelle à
l'indépendance du Liban alors que il est
pas vraiment daté pour ça mais il fait
il se trouve qu'il fait un discours à ce
moment-là à la place de son supérieur et
en 43 il va poser les premières réformes
en Algérie ailleurs les premières
brazzavilles etc la conférence de
Brazzaville donc il est convaincu que
l'Empire français mais il s'en sert en
1940 cette chose parce qu'en 1940 c'est
finalement la base arrière c'est ce qui
reste de la France c'est l'empire mais
il est profondément ma conviction c'est
qu'il est profondément anti colonialiste
d'emblée
dans l'Afrique subsaharienne en Algérie
bien entendu votre point de vue sur le
sujet oui
comme pour moi elle avait toujours 20
ans d'avance donc il sait très bien
qu'il va falloir se défaire de cette
empire qui est trop lourd alors
peut-être pas aller jusqu'à croire ce
que raconte à l'impératrite à
l'impérative lui parle lui dit quand il
dit à Peyrefitte ça serait pas quand on
met les deux églises ça serait colomber
les deux mosquées bon il y a des
boutades comme ça mais il est conscient
de du problème démographique et du poids
pour la France on ne peut pas garder cet
empire on ne peut pas avoir toutes ces
populations donc il le voit mais il ne
veut pas encore le dire donc comme
toujours il délivre les choses discours
après discours c'est très intéressant de
remonter la façon dont il lance un thème
avec une phrase et puis le discours
d'après il y a deux phrases et puis et
comme ça ça s'étale quelquefois sur 8
ans 10 ans
jusqu'à ce qu'ils révèle vraiment le
fond de sa pensée qui n'était pas
acceptable la première année je crois
qu'il est de Gaulle et l'Empire essayer
je pense que
une politique ou qu'une idée ne doit
être jugé à l'aune de l'intérêt ou de la
grandeur du pays si elle est utile à la
grandeur s'il est utile à la nation il
faut la garde il faut la conserver mais
si elle ne l'est plus il faut s'en débat
il y a un profond réaliste chez lui il y
avait une phrase de lui je sais plus il
n'y a pas de politique qui va en dehors
de la réalité des choses comme elles
sont si les communistes sont puissants
et si on peut équilibrer la puissance
des États-Unis en ayant des rapports
avec les Chinois ou avec les Russes ils
disaient les Russes il est pas les
Soviétiques mais il faut le faire c'est
communiste et alors etc etc et donc
c'est pareil pour l'Empire dès lors que
l'empire devient un boulet vous risque
de devenir un boulet parce qu'il
effectivement il avait une vision
d'anticipation quoi en se disant mais on
va garder l'Indochine qui est au bout de
la terre alors qu'on a 30000 soldats et
que c'est une vieille civilisation qui
forcément va se rebeller ça marchera pas
etc donc la garde d'Indochine il
l'amènera non
pas la voir soit de l'avoir fini soit de
l'avoir mené en début du bon sens enfin
globalement
il considère que l'empire devient un
handicap pour le rôle de la France dans
le monde dont il a une autre idée et
donc l'Algérie il est obligé de finasser
constamment parce que évidemment
beaucoup de Français veulent garder
l'Algérie toutes les élites
conservatrices et même socialiste à la
garder puis il y a les millions de
peignoires donc frontières compte etc
mais au fond de lui-même il se dit bon
d'ailleurs il y a une scène quand il va
faire le discours du 58 Alger donc il
dit je vous ai compris le fameux
chose d'ambigu parce qu'on prend
quelqu'un ça veut pas je vous ai compris
et ensuite il prend un verre de whisky
avec son gendre on me semble-t-il ils
sont peignoir parce qu'il fait chaud
fatigué et il dit à son gendre est-ce
que je suis pas allé trop loin
en disant je vous ai compris alors que
ça veut pas dire grand chose mais il se
disait je peux pas aller dans le sens
des pieds noirs ils sont ils s'en fout
ces gens-là d'ailleurs ils sont
souvenais parce qu'on a en 40 4 ou 3 les
Pieds-Noirs n'avaient pas beaucoup
soutenu ils étaient plutôt pétains et
donc il n'aimait pas trop les pieds
noirs mais il se disait est-ce que je
vais je vais pas trop dans le sens de de
la de la conservation de l'Algérie que
je ne veux pas conserver au fond de
moi-même en même temps il dit à
André-Philippe qui est un de ces
compagnons de route et qui qui est
associéiste en 43 il lui dira Philippe
tout ça se terminera par là à propos de
l'Algérie tout ça se terminera par
l'indépendance 43 donc il sait pas il
jette régulièrement des mais la pensée
profonde elle est je dis pas en
psychologue elle
des choses qui disent sauf si l'Empire
réussit à se réformer c'est une chose
qu'il écrit d'ailleurs dans le dans
l'armée de métier un moment donné il
parle il dit c'est une chance pour la
France d'avoir son empire mais enfin
peut-être faire attention aux
populations leur donner des droits et
cetera et puis il croyait à l'âme des
peuples démographique l'Union l'Union
française
il nous reste deux minutes
la fin de la vie politique de De Gaulle
c'est c'est 69 c'est ce fameux
référendum bien entendu avant ça il y a
eu 68 Baden-Baden pendant 24 heures de
Gaulle part en Allemagne réfléchir
j'imagine sous peser les options
possibles nous sommes à la fin du mois
de mai 68
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire au regard de
ce qu'on a vu dans ce documentaire de ce
qui a été l'attitude de De Gaulle en 68
justement là où certains ont pensé qu'il
avait vraiment perdu la main
c'est compliqué à dire je pense pas
qu'il est perdu la main d'abord je ne
sais pas qui a eu la main à ce moment-là
franchement Pompidou prétend qu'il l'a
eu mais enfin François Mitterrand l'a
pas eu beaucoup de gens l'ont pas eu
c'est un gratitude de la classe
politique un gratitude des Français
c'est est-ce que c'était dans cet état
d'esprit qui pouvait être Charles de
Gaulle effectivement il trouve tout ça
prend des proportions absolument
démesurées d'abord il est âgé tout de
même 68 en même temps je pense qu'il
peut toujours se dire qu'il aurait pu
être de Mao de l'époque c'est-à-dire
prendre le le parti de la révolution au
fond il était assez révolutionnaire mais
est-ce que 68 est une révolution c'est
la question est-ce que est-ce que
l'événement est à une telle importance
que de Gaulle on n'est plus en percevoir
lui qui avait l'habitude de
l'agrandissoire des grands événements
qui n'est plus en percevoir toutes les
données au fond c'est une espèce de
révolution sociale de révolution des
mœurs c'est pas beaucoup plus et donc je
pense qu'il n'est pas l'homme qui peut
effectivement tout à fait intégrer cette
idée là alors vraiment très peu de temps
l'enjeu s'il comprenait pas bien c'est
une de ces faiblesse la révolution des
mœurs du salut paraissait frivole
secondaire balterne etc et
factice donc un moment il y a un conseil
féministe et le ministre d'éducation qui
dit oui mais comprenez les étudiants
masculins veulent aller dans le recevoir
des filles c'est quand même un problème
etc
il a accepté la pilule donc qu'est-ce
qui était considérable pour rapport à ça
le voyage à Baden c'est pour moi c'est
oui c'est un coup de dés
c'est formidable ce voyage quelques
heures passées chez massue et puis il
revient
on aurait voulu passer beaucoup plus de
temps avec vous pour être honnête pour
évoquer
ce qui a été le parcours de De Gaulle
ont été ses origines familiales qu'on a
découvert dans ce documentaire
aujourd'hui vraiment un grand merci à
tous les trois là-bas participé à ce déb
at d'homme vos réactions ça sera sur
hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter merci à
sel massali qui m'a aidé comme à
l'accoutumée à préparer cette émission
et puis rendez-vous pour un prochain
débat doc et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à très bientôt
[Musique]